i've been married a few times
um
yeah i still believe in happily ever
after for sure that's jennifer lopez
confirming that benefit 2.0 may just get
a fairytale ending yeah i'm ready i'm
excited about it and who isn't after the
music superstar chatted with the today
show promoting the new trailer for her
and owen wilson's rom-com marry me
why not
yes
i'll marry you
you
all right your turn jennifer
those two words for what today host hold
a copy on behalf of all bennifer fans
asked lopez about possibly saying i do
in the future the two words marry me are
those two words you would like to hear
in the future
i don't know yeah i guess
i mean i you know me i'm a romantic i
always have been i've been married a few
times
um
yeah i still believe in happily ever
after for sure well done everyone the
flames of this rekindled romance just
got a little brighter you know it's wild
to think about it that way the mother of
two also shared why she isn't bothered
by her past marriages not working out
yeah i mean listen if you can't
laugh at yourself and
just take it as it comes i just don't
think about those things you know i feel
like i'm a human being like everybody
else i've had my ups and downs i've made
mistakes and i'm really proud of where
i've come to in my life and who i am as
a person as a mom
and as and as an actor and as a as an
artist meanwhile jlo's year has looked
like a real life rom-com with you know
who with ben affleck how's that amazing
that's jen and ben at the premiere of
his film the last duel last month where
the actor played coy about their
relationship
is it the j-lo glow like how much
happiness is she bringing into your life
because you're looking good man is it
the corduroy is that when she's big on
the corridor because i wasn't sure about
where they told me it's fall well
did she approve
okay look here's the thing while ben
remained tight-lipped with e.t
we did get new details about the romance
just turned out to be something really
magical last month a source close to the
couple told e.t quote j.lo and ben are
doing great and all has been good with
them both are working a lot but make
plans to spend time with the family as
well as each other hard to give it away
but it has a very good ending and
there's been no shortage of pda moments
from this couple
ben and jennifer turned all the heads at
the venice film festival which was
quickly followed by yet another night
out for the lovebirds
after jennifer's solo arrival at the met
gala the couple reunited inside and even
shared a mass kiss
[Music]